en tanzanie la sorcellerie concert force
et pouvoir elle est surtout bien moins
cher qu'un docteur qui lui-même se
trouvent souvent à plus de cinq heures
de piste
les sorciers eux habitent les villages
celui ci a des méthodes plutôt
surprenante pour soigner les douleurs
dont se plaint cet homme
[Musique]
en clair l'homme serait victime d'un
mauvais sort
[Musique]
s'il ya oui vie ok to share doumier a
cloché
maintenant que le mal est sorti par les
plaies le sorcier lui prépare une potion
protectrice
[Musique]
si l'asie ashoka in asia qui souffre
nazis apanga nazis ne sais pas par qui
la quittera quoi machine à huy il adore
le terme où on aurait obtenu un chrono
monde
reste maintenant à prouver l'efficacité
de son remède des petits coups pas bien
méchant mais suffisamment fort pour
impressionner le malade
certains sorciers le viennent devraient
barbare quand il s'agit de gagner
énormément d'argent
les incantations qui permettent
d'obtenir bonne fortune et réussite en
affaires sont très demandés par les
hommes politiques et les chercheurs d'or
pourtant ces hommes le savent pour cela
d'autres vont le payer de leur cher
quand ce n'est pas de leur vie ces
albinos sont victimes d'une superstition
meurtrière les sorciers prête aux
albinos des pouvoirs surnaturels suivant
le sort qu'ils ont acheté ou le gris
gris à confectionner
le sorcier réclame une partie de leur
corps ce professeur les recueils dans
son refuge
mais pour elisabeth le mal est déjà fait
une nuit pendant que je dormais deux
hommes sont rentrés dans ma chambre
ils ont braqué leurs torches sur moi et
puis ils m'ont coupé la main et ils se
sont enfuis
je sais qu'il m'a fait ça ils habitent
près de chez moi
quand ils ont été arrêtés ils ont dit
qu'ils avaient été enrôlés par le
sorcier de shinyanga c'est lui qui s'est
enfui avec ma main une main se négocie
autour de 500 euros pour un corps
d'albinos le sorcier peut réclamer
jusqu'à 70 mille euros la grande
pauvreté qui règne en tanzanie est en
partie responsable de ce massacre